e
hello if we could prepare to come to
order according to one of our clocks
it's 10:00 a.m. and agrees with my watch
so we will open the uh public hearing
63 the hearing is open is the sponsor of
the bill
present excuse
me thank you for the reminder and we
will of course begin our our meeting
with the Pledge of
Allegiance I'll ask uh representative C
please un States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God
indivisible liy and justice for all
thank you so
much okay we will now open the uh public
hearing on HP 463 do we have someone
here that looks like we do
representative
warry to introduce the
bill yes thank you Mr chair just a
moment um the sponsor has another
commitment during this time so I will be
introducing that for her on her behalf
um I'll
just read her testimony for the record
my name is Robert rep representative
Robert worry and I'm from the great town
of Hudson New Hampshire Hillsboro
District
13 um so I I'll be reading this
testimony on the board of recount for HP
463 um HP 463 is a straightforward Bill
designed to strengthen trust in our
local election recounts by addressing a
potential conflict of interest I suspect
that many of us have seen the
professionalism of the state's general
election recount firsthand efficient
impartial and well
observed but how many of us have been
part of a local election recount like
those for town or School
ballots here's what this bill hopes to
improve right now under current law the
same board members who write up and
recommend the warrant articles such as
school budgets Also Serve on the recount
board for those very same articles the
overlap risks undermining confidence in
the process even if no one intends any
harm let me share a quick example during
a recount that uh representative colum
petitioned for a School District budget
article she watched two school board
members miscount votes by marking them
in the wrong column honest mistakes
perhaps but they required repeated
Corrections worst one of those board
members kept block bling The Observer
view forcing the teams of observers
there to double up just to keep things
transparent so this is not to point
fingers or suggest bad faith uh I
believe that most involved in these
recount processes are good working
people working hard for their
communities but one shaky recount can
spoil trust and this seems to be an
oversight in the Statue HB 463 offers a
simple fix for Town ballot recounts the
school board and other impartial Fork
folks appointed by the moderator shall
make up the board of recount for school
ballot recounts the select board and
other neutral appointees make up the
board of recount no overlap no conflict
just fairness this isn't about politics
it's about practicality and protecting
what we all value A system that works
well like we all want it to hope this
committee will see HB 463 as a small fix
and a common sense step to deliver
confidence in the local recounts that
occur on occasion thank you for your
time and consideration that closes her
testimony thank you representative Barry
will you take questions from the
committee I will try thank
you are oh I see there is a question
representative
C thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um what happens if
there's uh a uh um if the board of
Selectmen are not in the same district
as the school board or I should say the
uh School Board encompasses more than
one
town well the re the it's my
understanding that the recount would be
in that particular locality and so it
would be applicable to that locality and
then it it's the matter
of combining or coating the different re
any recount that would occur across the
different voting Wards so this is for a
believe are there other questions from
the
committee seeing none thank you very
warry I have a uh request to testify
from deputy secretary Erin Hennessy
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Aaron Hennessy I am
the deputy secretary of state and I just
want to point out I believe the um the
sponsor of the bill or the person who
introduced the bill um noted but this
would um change the way we do recounts
right now and would require a select
board to take part in a recount of a
school board election and a school board
to take part in a recount of a select
Board election so it's something that is
not done currently and it um it's
something that um I just want to make
you aware of that um this is what this
bill actually does I'm happy to take
questions if you have any okay thank you
are there questions from the committee
uh representative
C thank you Mr chairman thank you
secretary for taking my question uh
would this do you feel that this would
entail more legislation then what's in
the
Bill thank you for the question I think
it pro it may I I would have to um
discuss this with our legal staff member
my concern would be with regards to your
earlier question of the sponsor with um
School boards that um are across
multiple towns and what that makeup
would be um and if it would require a
member of a school board that's not in
the town to conduct a recount of a
committee seeing none thank you very
testimony I have no further request for
Testimony so uh seeing that I
will
U adjourn the uh public hearing and
thank you for the blue sheet
representative okay the the public
hearing for HP 463 is hereby
adjourned uh our next uh public hearing
is scheduled for
1020 uh on the blue sheet we have uh one
uh person testifying that they're in
favor of this bill and I I do not have
access to the online testimony one of my
colleagues would care
to okay all right well thank you very
much you can let me know and I'll
announce it when I have it all right so
we will uh come back into session for
public hearing at 10:20 a.m. for h420 so
we have 15 minutes here quick uh I have
that number for you from the online
testimony okay is supporting is 13
opposed seven thank you very much
representative
Nome
e
yes hello everyone I've just been
informed that we have a Dartmouth Civics
group here today joining us in election
law and and I'm sure we're all very
pleased to see you and we hope your your
time with us is not only instructive but
very interesting thank you for being
here and for your interest we really do
appreciate
it
e
okay did you do the pledge did you do
the
pledge okay all right we're back um
going to open up the public hearing for
house P 420 uh nice well relative to the
chain of custody for bouts um going to
recognize
representative do I have a
representative for this bill
[Music]
um the is he here okay that's not a not
a good sign let me pull up the bill real
fast
420 okay a lot of stuff comes up when
you put in 420 uh all right
[Music]
um uh representative toner can you do us
the uh the honors of introduction for
per for introduction for purposes
see what we' got this might be the
shortest
uh shortest sh we have all day represent
toner welcome to election
law 420 House B
420 um representative Travis toner I
represent uh town of Belmont um and I'd
like to introduce House Bill 420
relative to chain of custody for ballots
and I will not be taking any questions
awesome I only have one pink card deputy
secretary say Aaron Hennessy SEC uh
recognized thank you Mr chairman good
morning everyone again Erin Hennessy
deputy secretary of state um this bill
should have a fiscal note attached to it
I don't believe our office was contacted
but we had a similar Bill last session
um I just want to give you a heads up
that this because of the amount of time
that you have to keep ballots uh we
would have I believe it would probably
cost between $5 and $220,000 a year for
our office if we wanted to purchase
sturdy reusable containers we did do a
pilot program um in the general election
um with some of these uh containers I
would say that they are not the ideal
container because the bottoms are not
flat so we had to put some cardboard in
the bottom so that the ballots wouldn't
fold um if there was a recount um but I
I will say that the um the town that did
use them um I believe it was sandborn
ended up purchasing them for their local
elections because they found them easy
to use um and um not having to use the
red tape they appreciated that um if you
were to go down this route I just wanted
you to make you aware of the fiscal
aspect of this and also ask you just to
clarify exactly the language that's in
in the LA in written in this
legislation
um reusable security containers I'm not
quite sure if you want to describe what
you mean by
security um locking containers is it a
container that self loocks or is it a
lockable
container um for the serialized
proprietary sealers our sealers right
now are not serialized they are um a
sticker with our seal on it um that we
um do not have serial numbers on WE
distribute them to local towns they
require the um signatures of the clerk
the moderators and the select board
members um and that's what makes them um
um a security aspect of the seals
themselves but they are not um
serialized um so I would just like
clarification are you looking for
serialized ual locks on the containers
the containers to be lockable or locking
themselves
um and the frangible paper seals I'm
assuming that means the seals that we're
already using um which are um you can
whip with a
knife and then finally the last part of
the bill deals with custody of the
boxes right now when the um a recount is
requested or if we do an audit of um
state election ballots our Secretary of
State's office goes to the local town
clerk the clerk will put on their uh
security log for the boxes that they are
signing the boxes out they will not be
returning and they're going to the
secretary's state Secretary of State's
office our office also has a log for the
boxes we create where we say this is
when we picked it up where we picked it
up from how many boxes there are and so
forth um there is not once we take
custody there is that is the log of when
we've taken custody there's no other
parts of custody of what we do with them
and who um and so the um I believe that
the last page of this needs some
clarification because once we have
custody we have custody of it and
there's not different times and dates of
our custody of the
boxes so I'm happy to take questions are
questions from the committee
representative wood thank you thank you
for taking my question
uh you said that this one town tried it
do you know how do you remember or know
how they locked the boxes sure thank you
for the question so it was a um a
plastic container um we got red ones for
the ballots blue ones for absentee
materials very similar to our cardware
boxes where we use um and um they kind
of closed like this and we put the paper
sealer over the top and then the um one
of the seals that we use for the ACU
vote device or the voting Works device
um where it has a number on it so they
write down on the actual paper sealer
the sealer that was used to um lock the
container representative your head thank
you Mr chair um thank you for taking the
question in your judgment do you think
that replacing our current containers
with the kinds of containers proposed in
this bill would improve the security of
ballots after the
vote thank you for the question
representative I don't have concerns
over the security of the ballots um we
have had some questions previously where
others have concerns because um just the
way the cardboard boxes look um we do
request that they reuse ones that we've
mailed to them with the ballots in it so
unless it's a brand new fresh cardboard
box that has not been taped before it's
not going to look the same as a box that
has been reused with the red tape over
it and then another new sealer put on
top of it so um the appearance I think
would be better for some people that
don't trust the security but I
personally do not have concerns with the
current
security y follow up from represent
actually representative toner's up I
apologize representative
wood thank you I just had a question of
who who has control of the seal tape and
um whether it's at the town
or at the SOS
office what of the seal tape this the
the security tape or whatever is used to
seal the boxes to make sure that like
they know if they've been opened or
tampered with the red tape yeah okay so
right now um the way we suggest uh that
people seal their boxes is that they um
they they seal them with packing
tape a strapping tape and a red security
tape um we've tested them um and we
distribute the red tape out to the local
clerks so between our office and the
clerks they are the ones with the access
to the tape the tape is not um in my
opinion um
100% it it is very sticky and red stuff
can get all over your hands when you're
using it but I think that the clerks do
a good job using
it for the represent Lane um thank you
and thanks for taking my question what
does the serialized tape I mean I guess
I'm not familiar with serialized tape
and what would it do or enhance to this
project thank you for the question that
was my question as I just want a
clarification on what that
meant representative
wey thank you Mr chair and thank you
deputy secretary for taking my question
um with regard to the paper containers
that are or cardboard containers that
are currently used have you seen
incidents where they've uh been stacked
too high and collapsed or things like
that and there's you know um so the
question is more is there an inherent
benefit of having better containers
because of the possibility of either
overtime deterioration or stacking and
you have a collapse of the uh boxes
thank you for the question yes we have
seen in instances where um
a a seal a corner of the cardboard has
broken because it was dropped or
something and it doesn't have anything
to do with the tape um but the Box
Integrity itself and I think it might
have to do with how much recycled papers
put into cardboard boxes these
days uh representative wood thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
you said that you saw the you've seen
the boxes and they probably haven't
looked pretty not I'm not trying to put
words in your mouth but I'm just trying
to figure out that do they look secure
to you even though we're not looking for
pretty but do they look like if someone
went in or out you would know it thank
you for the question so I haven't seen
every single box there is but on of the
boxes that I have seen at polling
locations um when I'm there to observe
them being sealed or the ones that we do
see at recounts I haven't had any
personal concerns with them they do look
sealed
thank representative
toner trying to go in order here are you
familiar with um the process of securing
evidence and chain of um chain of
custody is that possibly what this is
trying to duplicate thank you for the
question no I am not pres mhe head thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking the
question um curious do you know if
there's a a standard a common practice
among the 49 other states that hold
elections the administr elections for
for storing ballots are are card
cardboard boxes the norm are is there a
certain type of Ballot Box that everyone
else is
using thank you um so I did Reach Out
multiple times um at to my colleagues
across the country on to find out what
they use because I am trying to find the
perfect container for our ballots
without making it too heavy um so that
people can pick them up and stack them
put them away and store them um there is
not I haven't found a standard one um
there was stackable containers that were
previously used in Maine that may still
be used in some main locations that are
metal um I don't know that I would
recommend going to metal it just seems a
little dangerous and heavy um but I have
not found a standard one so if somebody
wants to create a business I think that
might be a good idea thank you
representative Wei thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question um with
regard to the serialized um aspect I
think perhaps what the sponsor was
trying to get at is can each individual
box be specifically identified and is
you know how is that uh handled now
maybe maybe that would help the
committee understand the uh that aspect
bill so I will say that our cardboard
boxes are not
serialized how it's handled now is that
the um the labels on the Box on the
paper sealers that we use are supposed
to be labeled box one of how many so if
there's 20 total boxes for the election
um the first one should should be box
one of 20 two of 20 and so forth so
that's how one would know how many boxes
there're supposed to be for that
election and then the clerk will put
that on her log the boxes that she is or
he is maintaining in their office
securely further questions seeing none I
don't have any other pink cards um
representative gzowski if you could grab
me the blue sheet
online this hotly contested
Bill
hp420 had uh six in support and seven
opposed and zero neutral I think we have
asked more questions than people testify
online um and then on the blue sheet is
blank so having no other pink cards of
members members of the public wishing to
speak I'm going to close the executive
session on House Bill 420 the committee
will stand in recess until 10:40 for
e
it's 10:40 and it's time to open the
public hearing on HP 492 and I see the
sponsor representative Horgan and you
that's fine if it's pass around that's
okay it won't
affect all right so uh representative of
Horgan when you're ready thank you for
being here well thank you very much I'm
resident Timothy Horgan from straford
County District 10 the town of Durham um
the home University of New Hampshire and
actually I'm a former resident for about
five or six years in in Hanover and I
see a bunch of uh I see a group of uh
Dartmouth students and Dartmouth is a
great school I mean it pains me to admit
that because I myself went to rival
School Columbia but um it was a good
nature of rivalry now if we had crowd of
students from Princeton or Harvard well
I guess I would still be glad to see
them too but but um so this is HB 492
it's basically uh about recounts when
you have wrin after primary where no one
has filed to run so um this was we had
an incident which happened last year in
my County which is straford county um
well during the state primary on
September 10th 2024 so the Republican
Party had no candidates for the district
free county commissioner race and
actually there's been a um there have
been many bills in this house related to
the straford county commissioner
districts most of which though happily
for you people have been a municipal and
County government but anyway nobody
filed for the District 3 county
commissioner race and so no one filed
during the June filing period no one was
chosen to fill the vacant slot on the
primary ballot immediately after the
filing period which parties can do also
like nobody step forward to run a uh
right in campaign however a Democrat did
get enough W in votes on September 10th
2024 this was longtime County
Commissioner George mcis and he was oo
un opposed in his own party's primary
and um guess the interest of full
disclosure I did vote for him and I'm a
longtime friend of his and anyway he got
just barely enough votes 35 to be listed
on the Republican column in the general
election and there only 20 other
Republican Wy votes in the September
10th primary I think they were all
tallied of the sort which they tallied
as a as
scatter and
um a document I don't have with have
with me but which I could I know where
if the Secretary of State's office could
provide you as the tally sheet from the
county from um you know tally sheet from
the towns and uh City and there's some
City Wards in do and Rochester which are
in straford County Comm District three
so that um that might be useful piece of
information because uh the I think the
Republicans had some doubt about whether
or not they were accurate so they
so um I mean I makes I'm satisfied they
they were accurate but there um you know
there those things are written out by
hand so sometimes a little bit hard to
discern what exactly it is they're
saying but so rent Kelly Penza a
republican from Rochester on behalf of
the straford county Republic committee
asked for recap and but she was turned
down both by the Secretary of State and
the ballot law Commission on the grounds
that she had no standing to ask for such
a recount since she she did not run for
County Commissioner as a writing
candidate I guess that would have been
legally questionable because she's also
a uh ran ran for State Rep and was
reelected uh reelected easily but anyway
and there was so she wasn't qualified to
ask for writing candidate the under the
current law the county committee wasn't
um had no standing and the state
committee didn't have any standing in
fact there really wasn't anybody who had
standing now commissioner mcis if he had
hypothetically gotten 34 votes in the
ini election night count could have
asked for a recount and so
um I mean like the straford County's
County Republican desire for recount was
understandable I could probably
understand if this had happened to a
Democrat although I mean of course there
were there certainly were several they
certainly had several opportunities to
you know stop this from happening you
know they could have convinced somebody
to file they could have named they could
have named somebody in June when they
had the opportunity they could have also
like talked somebody running and writing
campaign but they didn't do any of these
things but still they were their
displeasure with the situation was
understandable so what this bill does it
passed it hence force allows the state
party committees to ask for recounts for
situations similar to the September 10th
2024 District 3 county commissioner race
and I think there actually have been
some recounts of writing candidates in
in other races um although although even
though commissioner mcgis was not
popular with the straford County
Republican leadership he actually was
pretty popular with the voters um
almost I think what it says my testimony
almost 90% of the voters in the County
Commission their District voted for them
so there were about uh 23,000
votes for mcis in the November general
election and only about 3,000 undervotes
so I mean even though he was a very
popular candidate with Republicans
Democrats and independents the like you
I can still see a situ I still see a
situ where it might have been
appropriate that let somebody have a
recount and so this would allow the
state parties to do it and they would
pay the usual uh cost cost for recount
and there's whole procedure in the laws
as you probably know better than I
for estimating the cost and collecting
the money from
the uh Party Committee so that's um
that's my bill I think it's a I think
it's a fairly simple change it's uh it's
a bipartisan Bill we need a little bit
more bipartisanship around here so I
urge you to pass it I'd be happy to take
any
questions okay thank you representative
are there any questions from the
committee uh representative Lane thank
you and thanks for taking my question
what happens if the person is a um
indeep an
independent so I guess they wouldn't
have been already been on the other on
the primary ballot if that happened I
just I thought of that as you were
talking but it might not come up I wish
I thought of that before I was talking I
do know that you have to be registered
as a member of a party to file in a in a
primary I believe you can actually be
nominated in a primary um without being
registered in a party and I know there
was a uh right in for state senate this
last cycle with Michael York who's a
state librarian he used to work right
across the street from here um until he
recently retired so he um he wanted to
run as a Democrat for his state senate
seat and he was a uh turns out he's a
register independent but he did uh file
run a writing campaign was successful
and was did shown as a Democrat on the
ballot I don't don't know specifically
whether he changed his party
registration during that process so like
in there have been cases where
Independents have been nominated through
a right in and the primary I know um so
hope that answers your question as best
I can so that might be something you can
look at in a work session if you want to
have it but are there other questions
from the committee oh yes representative
Bay thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Oran for taking my
question uh I'm curious in this uh your
your statement where uh you had a
hypothetical that had uh commissioner
mlar has gotten 34 votes he had a
standing to ask for recount what's by
what statute is that I don't even I have
the print out of the statute here but
it's somewhere I believe in RSA 660
postelection procedure I believe so I um
I sort of have this answer possibly with
my fingertips but anyway so that's uh
there's a there's a whole law about the
recount and how depending on how close
it is like whether you have to pay for
it and and so forth I'm probably not the
best best person to ask and so
unfortunately the deputy secretary of
state stepped out so she would probably
be more like likely to have the answer
at her fingertips than I do but yes so
but people people have asked there have
been recounts for in right in primaries
before so does happen on occasion
so any other question follow followup
certainly thank you so uh could you uh
just tell us what it says even if you
summarize it in your own words like well
the rec well depending on how close it
is and this applies I think even to a
Right End candidate if if you're if
within a certain margin that depends on
the number of votes in the election you
can you don't have to pay a fee I
myself had to had to survive a recount
in primary to a voter citizen to a rival
who is actually you know filed to be in
the ballot and uh then if it's uh
outside of that then you there's a
there's a sliding fee scale and then if
you're you know if you're totally yeah
if then if you're like you know totally
outside the parameters then you have to
pay for the cost of the recounts you
have to pay for all those people to like
hang out and do their thing at the uh at
the at the state at the state archives
all day so which
uh a lot of the so the the secretary a
lot of the uh people who are actually
doing the county are actually paid a
token amount to do it so there's some
cost to it and secretary state will
estimate that and then you can decide
whether or not you want to go forward
with it so usually usually the process
is very is very very accurate so like so
there's usually not much point to ask
for a recount unless you're within a
very few votes of of of either very very
few votes of like of of of winning
there's usually no point in asking for a
recount but you can if you want it's a
little bit different the right and
that's a little bit more ambiguous
because the clerks have to make a
judgment on what what constitute a vote
for person and what didn't so like I
know for example
uh I think with the mlar race or some
people who it me seems like a pretty
simple name it's spelled phonetically
and everybody in straford County knows
him but I guess there may have been a
few people who didn't spell his name
consistently I know I know in the uh
first and Nation presidential primary we
had like a lot of write him votes for
Biden I know like my I for some reason
decided I should write Joseph R Biden
instead of Joe Biden like all the other
people in Durham did but they U they
decided to count my ballot in the Joe
Biden column even though I'd written
Joseph R Biden because I knew that was
the same person
but it's kind of hopefully that answered
your question somewhat longer answer
than I probably needed to give but are
there other questions from the committee
oh yes representative news thank you
very much thanks for taking the question
uh what is the standard of uncertainty
is it 30 is that close enough to 35 is
40 too many what do you mean by
uncertainty um I I don't um actually I
don't have the specific number for that
that's probably uh but it's uh certainly
in terms of the fee schedule it's by the
number of votes that you have so
certainly uh you know if you got only if
you didn't get any W in votes it would
be absurd to write for a re recount if
you got say so if you wanted if you had
34 votes you would be reasonable to ask
for a recount to make sure you in fact
maybe picked up another vote that they
missed somewhere or also and also you
can tell sometimes also you can see by
the right in sheet some if they wrote
down a name that you think should have
been yours and wasn't yours like uh so
actually so say if somebody written like
I don't know John mcis instead of George
mcis you could have George could have
like asked to have that counted as for
himself so that U that's more of a
question for the Secretary of State's
office who has and the deputy secretary
of state stepped out of the room but I'm
sure you can I'm sure you can get an
answer to to the question from them so
further questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much
representative not seeing any other pink
cards indicating a desire to testify or
anyone appearing to want to
testify uh representative gzowski would
you get the blue sheet please and can
you look up the
online yeah uh online was 99 SP one
opposed
and I see no input on the signup sheet
or uh testimony so with that I will
close the public hearing for HB 492 the
a.m.
e
okay it's 11:00
a.m. so we'll open up the public hearing
for House Bill 574 requiring background
checks of the private companies and
their contractors who program and
maintain New Hampshire voting machines
and we'll recognize our own
representative Burnham for the purpose
of introduction and without objection
representative Burnham will be allowed
to return to her seat to uh conduct her
thank you Mr chairman and fellow
committee members I am representative
Claudine bernham representing St
representing straford District 2 Milton
Rochester w 5 I am introducing HB 574 FN
requiring background checks of private
companies and their contractors who
program and maintain New Hampshire
voting machines this is essential to our
election Integrity Prof process we want
to ensure that our ballot counting
devices are being maintained and
programmed with the utmost security and
since the machines are programmed and
maintained by company employees it is
only right to have every person involved
in this process to pass a level of
security with a background check these
machines determine the winners of our
leaders in our governments and we want
to ensure our voters that their machines
are processed by vetted
employees this bill is attached with a
note and I'm not sure why since most if
not all companies contracted with the
government require background checks for
sensitive roles in National Security and
since our federal elections are
conducted on voting machines I believe
that would be grounds for National
Security even if the state believed they
were required to pay for background
checks LHS
associate employees between 11 to 31
employees and voting Works employees
between 11 to 50 employees not all
employees program and maintain the
voting machines either so this number
can potentially be much lower the
average cost of a comprehensive
background check is about
$50 the most this would cost the state
is about
$4,050 not the $25
$500,000 that is estimated in this um in
this bill most employees only need one
background check at the beginning of
employment not to be repeated every
year and uh and from what I understand
sometimes the background checks last a
few years so there's there's that
possibility of reduction of costs even
um even if it were the projected cost
stated in this bill we do also have Hava
funds that would certainly be able to
cover the cost of the this essential
process for voter trust this bill is a
common sense bill with transparency
security and
accountability thank you for your
consideration in voting this bill in so
our voting machines can be programmed
and maintained by verifiable and trusted
employees of LHS Associates and the
voter works thank you questions from the
committee represent
Lane thanks for taking my question I
know he had his hand up too I
know um
uh this is requiring that you you put P
information Social Security numbers and
information on the the social the
secretary's website am I reading that
correctly um it requires
submission of the state who will then
make the information publicly available
websites um I'm reading the methodology
yeah it's right somebody said line 11 on
page
one um that's not the part that I
believe that's been addressed in this
RSA it's just um
I don't
know it just sends a list of current
employees programming and maintaining
electronic can I follow I don't think it
has yes follow I think it's the
identification number that we're
referring
to and I don't know if that's right
employee identification number if that's
their social security number or what
that
yeah I don't know what that number is
that's um that wasn't in my proposal so
to speak but
um I don't I don't think that that's
referring to a soci security number but
number further questions from the
committee representative
weary so uh last fall it was discovered
in the software code of the machines
that the Ukrainian national anthem had
been programmed in and other cyber
security bugs were also found do you
think that
the uh background checks might uh
prevent this kind of nonsense from
occurring in our New Hampshire election
programming uh for our ballot
machines uh I certainly think that's a
it's a possibility I'm I'm not a
programmer but um
I I would hope that any type of
background check would at least start
the process of ensuring that security
measure
so uh represent
n I'm just sitting where my name tag
ended up so thank
you um on page two it says that the
results of the um background check shall
be publicly available are you aware of
any other required background checks
available I am not I'm not well vers
with background checks and what what
availability that there is on that
so I do not know thank you followup yep
follow up um if something comes back as
sort of a positive hit does anything in
this bill prevent that person from
um not this particular bill I would I
would assume that that would be a
criminal issue or some type of it would
fall under another um law of some sort
activity further questions
representative
C thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative taking my question on the
page one line u 10 it talks about
reports every month does that mean the
uh the company has to uh get a uh
Security check on each employee every
month what line was that
um I wasn't aware that that was actually
written that way
why further questions from the
committee I have one um representative
Burnham would you believe that I have to
undergo a background check every um 3 to
5 years to work in a child career it
cost
$28 I would believe that cuz I have been
involved with um children's ministry and
other um an in Town recreation where
I've had numerous background checks uh
each time that I started and uh once
that started it was um acceptable for
three years and followup would you also
believe that that background check
includes a digital fingerprinting that's
sent through the FBI database yes I
would believe that because I have had my
hands um digitally fingerprinted for
that use
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you I don't believe I
have any other pink cards so
representive gasowski if you could grab
me that I thought of a
sheet and online 574 had 113 support 11
opposed and zero
neutral on the blue sheet it's not blank
so I got to look at it thought we're
we had two people signed up against uh
who did not speak having no other
members of the public wishing to speak
on House Bill 574 I will close the
public hearing on House Bill 574 and the
11:20
e
all right we are 11:20 we're going to
open the public hearing on House Bill
497 requiring the periodic evaluation of
the forms and procedures related to
performing voter checklist duties and we
will recognize our own representative
Wei for the purpose of introduction
thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable committee members my name is
Robert Wy I have the privilege of
representing the great town of Hudson
Hillsboro District
13 um this bill is a simple Bill and it
really uh proposes sort of a pilot um
type of study
whereby the Secretary of State's office
would periodic ially evaluate the forms
and procedures for usability and
determine resource and time requirements
for the completions of forms and the
performance of the procedures um in
reviewing the rsas there's very few
places that talk about how the forms
and other procedures that are used by
our election officials are handled by
the Secretary of State in uh RSA 65 5222
for the election manual it does say
something to the effect of or let me
quote exactly the manual shall be
written in non-technical language so
that's the only place really that I've
sort of found where there's a uh
prescription for how procedures and
forms are to be written and the thought
was there there is this science called
human factors engineering it's used a
lot in the medical device industry which
I'm very familiar with and the uh aspect
to it um is that basically anything that
is potentially complicated should be
evaluated carefully and determine that
the people who would be normally tasked
with with performing those Duties are
um uh provided procedures and forms that
evaluate their ability to use those
forms and and that they can be used
without too much
complexity and uh any loss of
proficiency in handling their those
procedures so the idea behind this bill
is very simple you just uh allow the
Secretary of State to periodically
evaluate the forms uh of use uh for
usability uh I started really with the
checklist procedures because this is uh
maintaining the voter roles to me is one
of the cornerstones to election
integrity and also so we know from uh
the experiences in the last general
election that there were extremely long
lines due to same day registration in
some areas so it's it would seem to make
sense that this could be an area that
could at least uh be evaluated so that
is the essence of this um I'll happy to
take any questions if there are
any are questions from the
committee oh there
are okay representative we'll just go
left to right start representative
Bay thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um when you say uh
periodically do you have a notion of the
period because you know we can go to
extremes of really short or really long
I mean such that you know every 10 years
is a period every day is is periodic so
what what's what's what are you thinking
about ideally I think um
most often usability just speaking from
medical device experience um most often
usability is a big initial evaluation
and then it's minor periodic reviews
that occur typically with updates to
procedure so if we had a change in the
law then there would be an evaluation of
of the usability and how that is impact
uh or how the procedures and forms are
impacted by a change to the RSA so
that's
the um that's the kind of nature of how
it's done in at least other Industries
so I would expect the periodic is based
mostly upon RSA changes but it you know
on occasion it might be a a multi-year
cycle so three to five years could could
be also another standard that could be
used in that
case uh representative Gilmore
thank
you I I was it's pretty much the same
question but I'm actually looking for a
definition of periodic if that could be
possible and something to think about in
terms of because again I'm up in the air
what what it means and you you explained
something you know just prior to this
and um maybe if you could put it in
writing in some manner that would be I I
because I don't know how um excuse me I
don't know how the Secretary of State or
other people would interpret it
so I think there should be greater
Clarity if that's
possible I uh thank you for your
question
um I I think it it could be perhaps
amended to something along the lines of
uh evaluated at least every five years
or sooner if necessitated By changes to
the
suitable we're going around the table so
yeah um we got to go to well we'll go
representative
new thank you very much um thanks for
taking the question uh do you know what
the secretary state's office does now
even though it's not in a sha language
like your proposal but are they
reviewing the forms and procedures at
this
point I I would say certainly that there
not just in in
basic
discussions um not perhaps specifically
about this bill but in basic discussions
there is no one who
has
um uh human factors engineering
background or a uh another parallel
thing to this would be industrial
psychology um so there is no one who has
sort of that background to my
understanding reviewing these forms and
representative Ward oh oh he got you
okay uh further questions from the
committee seeing none I don't have any
uh thank you representative weary I
don't have any pink
cards um so representative gaski if you
could grab the blue sheet and online we
had I don't know why I clicked off of it
blank uh okay we'll grab it um and then
was where's the
summary hold on let me Let me refresh it
it's not it's not a hotly contested bill
but I want to read the they're not
showing the summer anymore which kind of
sucks um it it was like split but it was
like seven and eight it was I can't
count it up without the summary so my
apologies I don't know why the summary
is not working all right with that we
will close the public hearing on House
Bill 597 and we will stand in recess
until
11:40 Mr chair um my on my computer it
says it was four and support nine
opposed on the summary for that for
not
Sol
for
e
it is 11:40 and it's time to open the
public hearing on HP 514 FN this public
hearing is now opened I recognize
representative Barry to introduce the
bill he has sponsored thank you um yes
uh my name is representative rosb
represent we the towns of wear in gtown
I'm here to introduce 514 allowing
private person Su violations of election
law um so this came about in a lawsuit
that I filed uh with a state senator uh
in regards to what we viewed as an abuse
of R uh in one of the sections of RC 659
and the last Clause of RSA 659 mentions
the Attorney General um and the
enforcement procedures for the entire
chapter and what the court the court
took the position that only the Attorney
General can um can uh basically
adjudicate something can adjudicate a
violation of 659 so if the if the
Attorney General's office the Department
of Justice deems that there's no
violation you as a private individual
have no recourse uh for any part of the
chapter which is actually really
dangerous um so the first thing is is I
believe you have a right um as a citizen
to seek redress from your government and
one person should not be able to
determine whether or not you get to seek
redress and there's all sorts of things
in the
659 that both sides of the aisle should
be interested in the potential to be
able to file a lawsuit in court over um
for instance if you are denied the right
to vote and the court takes the position
that only the doj can um a can can
pursue a violation of 659 and they take
Court takes that position you're done
that's it you don't get to vote um in my
case I was suing over an electioneering
issue which is also under 659 but 659
handles election procedures so if you
see something that's a gross abuse of
the process uh and the doj disagrees
with you one person the doj disagrees
with you it's over for you you don't get
to seek redress so this is an attempt to
allow uh private individuals if they
don't believe they've had their concerns
redressed by the doj to bring a lawsuit
into court uh it does have in there some
qualified immunity uh protections at the
very last section um to so we don't have
that kind of chilling effect on suing a
person on the personal level um but that
is the intent of the law that is the it
also has a provision I should say it has
a provision about um if you suspect that
RSA 659 is being violated the first
thing you have to do is go to the doj uh
and the doj has five days to say hey
yeah something's wrong here something's
not wrong here the exception being is if
with you're if you're within two weeks
of an election so 15 days of an election
uh and then you can go straight to court
um because obviously if they're delaying
the doj is delaying you should be able
to seek redress because the immedate of
the matter requires you to go around
them but so I try to create a framework
of first you got to go to the doj if
you're really close to the an election
or on Election Day and you see
something's going on that's wrong um you
should be able to go to court and seek
redress um so with that I'm happy to
take
questions oh thank you are there
questions from the
committee uh representative
C uh thank you um Mr chairman and thank
you for representive for taking my
question for sure I call you chairman
I'm representative right now although I
I may try to do the thing where I you
know say who person the
uh does does this mean that you have to
go to the doj first and only if they
deny you that then you have standing to
go to court no uh so you have to go to
the doj first and let them attempt to
act right because they may solve your
problem right the doj may solve your
problem and then you don't need to go to
court um so that that's the intention is
you got to go you go with the exception
of the two-e window um you got to go to
the doj first which is the procedure now
at least as what the courts have said um
but if you don't like what they do or
they say there's not a problem or they
say they're not going to act on it um
and you feel that you're being violated
um you're being you're suffering harm
then you get to go through the court
system and this includes things like
registering to vote if your moderator
denies you a ballot um and you feel that
you should be able to ballot they won't
let you out um you know a challenge
voter affidavit or something like that
some sort of relief mechanism that we've
built in that may or may not be there
anymore um but this this allows you to
kind of seek relief through the judicial
system which you're supposed to be able
to do you're supposed to be able to seek
relief through the Judiciary um and for
some reason the Judiciary has recited
that no you don't get to do that because
of the very last line in RSA 659 which
they have interpreted it says only the
doj the Attorney General um can push
claims of RSA 659 through the
courts thank you are there other
questions from the committee I I see
there are uh representative Mirad first
thank you Mr chair um at I'm trying to
figure out at uh
present you you mentioned that there's a
there there's something in 659 about how
the provisions of election procedure are
enforced or how violations are I guess
um prosecuted and I haven't been able to
find that it's the very last very last
section um and it mentions the Attorney
General's office you'll see it's I think
it's the second it's the last I don't
have it in front of me but it's the last
uh it's the last little section it's I
think it's section A I think there's a
two-part section A and B and I believe a
is the one that mentions the doj or the
Attorney General's office I don't have
it in front of me um but it's in there
and the courts have interpreted that as
being only the doj can pursue the
violations of
659 representative wood do you still
have a question
I do thank you for taking my question
you mentioned that um the you had a
personal problem along these lines um
the way the law was written was it
intended to be that way from your
understanding about uh basically they
being the last um last stop as far as a
result I I don't know I haven't I
haven't looked into it um I
it the answer is I don't know my my full
response would be I don't care um
because I believe at my core you have a
you have a right to go to court uh you
have a right to do that and you have a
right to seek redress through your
government and I fully reject the idea
that one person um the Attorney General
gets to make a determination and that's
the end of it and you can you can suffer
abuse and you could see how that and I'm
not claiming you know I obviously with
my particular case I disagreed with what
the doj's determination was I wasn't
quiet about that and I still disagree
with their determination on it um but
when when I when I went to go seek
redress to the court um I was not I was
I was able to make my case to the court
but the court ultimately said it doesn't
matter if your case it doesn't matter if
the judge agreed with me or not only the
doj gets to make this determination
because of the language that's in RSA
659 in the last
section thank you and I just disagree
with that premise I just I and that
could happen at any point in that
section so there's stuff in there that
my friends on the right like there's
stuff in there that my friends on the
left like one person could get in there
and just be like no I'm not enfor that
today or they could do disproportionate
enforcement and you would be there
nothing you could do about
committee okay uh representative
Lane representative Lane go ahead please
uh thanks for taking my question sorry
um I was looking at the attorney's fees
section yeah um and it's on page
two um it it says that no attorney
representative shall charge or collect
fees for legal services rendered unless
the fees have been approved by the
superior court
[Music]
so how do you then get hire an attorney
to get you into
court before they've had their fees
approved yeah uh I mean my goal here so
the answer is you can't right that's
built in the law intentionally I don't
want this to be a cash grab I I want
want this to be a there's harm being
there's harm that is occurring and you
you as a private individual need to be
able to go you can as you know
representative Lane you're an attorney
you can file prosay in New Hampshire
Court um and if you think you have a
good argument you can make it but no you
can't we're not going to be sitting here
patting up the pockets of attorneys um
and because you can imagine there's a
lot happening at 659 there's a lot of
moving pieces there um and things happen
by accident some things happen by
accident some things happen by intention
right um and that's why we have the
release valve at the very end um for
things that are accidents are not a big
deal um but I don't want I don't want to
open up a Floodgate Of lawsuits um and I
don't want inter attorneys encouraging
said lawsuits because they think that
it's a Payday coming I want you be able
to seek red address through the judicial
system which I once again I go back to
right I'm going to proceed with
representative Mirad first and then you
thank you Mr chair um I'm also trying to
just ascertain the nature of the
lawsuits that would be filed so this
these are civil suits there are
individuals being harmed by a violation
of election procedure um are they
charging the state with harming them so
the state would be the defendant in
every in every case um or are they
charging individuals um who are working
in the polls with violating with harming
them uh so there is a section I believe
it's first page um I believe there is a
section of that excuse me let me let me
find it here we go it's uh second page
uh line 12 claims filed against state
and its agent that goes into the details
of that um and what that talks about
there is basically the the state the
state is the first kind of person um but
if you try to go after that person on
individual level um it's very easy for
them to drop off um I I don't know if I
answered that question well um but that
that sex the language in there to answer
that is in this bill um
that we're not I I don't want to set up
a system where people are trying to sue
their moderator they're trying to sue
their selectman I don't want to set that
system up um I want to set up a system
where if you're being harmed you can
seek redress and one person is not the
gatekeeper to your to your ability to
fix a
problem tried to put a lot of I try to
put a lot of restraints on it
representative Lane you had a
followup um it's my understanding and I
don't know this about Superior Court but
um in a lot of the courts and I've been
practicing for a while but 50% of the
suits are
prosay um and actually prosay people
tend to um uh the cases take longer so
my concern is that you are opening the
floodgates for anybody who's not happy
to file this this prosay because they
and
the so prosay is I I
think you but you don't agree with that
you don't think having it prosay is
gonna increase the number of lawsuits I
I I would never I would never take the
position that someone should not be able
to file pray because I I believe at my
court anybody should be able to go to
the court and seek redress um and as to
the immediacy of it that's that's just
kind of one of those problems with an
election right it has a defined Point as
a Define Point has to happen um and I
remembered I forgot to answer part of
Representative mir's question so I want
to okay go back to he asked what type of
Suits would be filed we're talking about
TR temporary restraining orders um uh
injunctions that sort of stuff to seek
to seek relief from the
court know if if somebody's telling you
you can't vote and you believe that you
can vote and you should be able to go to
a court and if a court says yes this
person can vote the Court's going to
issue a court order for you to go vote
yeah I have one more followup yes go
ahead please it kind of pings off of uh
representative Mirad in that situation
where you denied the right to
vote would you be suing the city or the
town or the Secretary of State because
the people that are denying you the
right to vote are actually the town or
the city not the secretary of state so
you in that case you would go after the
the Town M because they're the ones
administering the
election you have to be able to go after
the person who's doing or the person the
The Entity that's doing the harm
right representative wry thank you Mr
chair um and thank you for taking my
question I just I'm I'm trying to kind
of summarize this so it's a fundamental
right to petition the government for a
redress of grievances in your particular
situation you had an unelected official
stop your ability to
redress your grievances because they
basically said no we're not acting on it
the courts then interpreted that as lack
of standing and would not act on it
correct
of enabling
standing in the ca where elected
officials are more responsible is am I
mistaking that or you're you're enabling
standing to go in front of the court and
plead your
case because they to in my particular
case they tossed out they tossed out my
case due to standing and it's not it's
not about my particular case because
I've already solved my issue um with
that with that legislation my issue is
is if there's other when I when they
took when the court took that position
it scared me because now there's a
gatekeeper for justice and we have a
Department of Justice there's a reason
for it but if your rights are being
violated you should be able to go to the
courts and have those issues addressed
in a court of law which has always been
a fundamental First Amendment first it's
it's a fundamental part of our process
you have a right to seek redress um and
I just don't like the idea of a singular
person being able to say no to that you
should be able to go through the court
system it's why the court exists um they
are reason why we have three bodies um
and I I just don't think one person in
the executive branch telling you no
should be the reason why you just have
to
stop are there further questions from
the committee representative Mirad thank
you Mr chair I wanted to just return to
that attorney's fee section lines 25 and
following on page
two um and I just wonder about like this
sort of hypothetical suppose that I
think I've been harmed because election
procedure hasn't been
followed and uh and I and I being a
lawyer snob go out and hire an attorney
who charges $750 an hour and get that
attorney to help me compose a complaint
and file it um with Attorney General's
office and then file in Superior Court
would that contract that I've that
private contract that I've entered into
with this attorney would that contract
be null and void as a consequence of
this section yeah that's a great
question I don't have an answer answer
to it um and the more broader point is
I'm not dying on the hill of attorney
fees I just don't want I'm trying to
avoid the situation of attorneys
actively encouraging these suits versus
a private individual trying to move
forward on their own um but I said it's
not it's not the hill that I'm dying on
I'm just I was trying to when I crafted
this I tried to go in and build the
build the safeguards and stop abuse in
advance understanding that we are
opening the
gates are there further question from
the
committee representative Lane well at
least you know I read
it um thanks for taking the question in
one of the and it comes back to the
question I had about whether you see the
city or the state um in one of these
sections the new sections D colon 4 it
says files claimed against the state and
its agent but there's not a
similar um it so if you're bringing it
against the city would that fall under
D5 so I'm just making sure it didn't IM
get left out so it's on line 12 page two
and then line
18 so to your point I mean D5 says lines
19 and 20 says against another party I
would I would assume that that would I I
would interpret that as meaning the
towns I certainly mean it I certainly do
mean it to so if you're asking what my
intent is yes but I I believe that
covers it um once again I'm not I'm I'm
not a uh I'm definitely open to changes
it's not a it's not a my way or the
highway on the bill but all right thank
you further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much representative for your
testimony I have uh one individual who's
uh requested to testify representative
forgan thank you very much for being
recognized well we'll uh leave it it
where he left it and he'll hopefully be
able to find it
easily right he's like me he has the
ringer turned off all the time so okay
well thank you please if you want to
reach me on the phone you have to leave
me a Google voicemail but anyway so I'm
represent Timothy Horgan straford County
District 10 which is the town of Durham
and um I just feel this I think this
bill goes goes way too way too far well
first of all I'm not going to say it's
necessarily in the wrong committee but
they're putting it in a chapter of the
law books which would normally you know
the purview of the committee I belong to
Judiciary although I'm glad we have
plenty of bills over there so I'm just
as happy they didn't send it to us which
is the law book about proceedings in
special cases so it's not in the
election law book but it is a election
issue so that part of it's fine um looks
like has a very expansive definition of
person which I think actually includes
political subdivisions which usually
aren't considered persons for in other
areas of the law so that's um so now was
just just about anybody to sue just
about anybody associ with elections I
think it's like just goes very far and
with elections addition to the
doj and um you know there's a election
law there is a uh Department that in the
department uh while they be across the
street now up the road which deals with
election issues and I found them been
very very helpful regardless of your
political persuasion if you believe
there's an election law violation and I
actually a few years ago actually filed
one against uh somebody and well I guess
they did not prosecute the person but uh
I thought they were very
helpful in regards to that so this is a
in addition to the doj who I think
actually you know do a good job like
whether the there's also um if if it
includes the uh if it affects the result
of the election there's also the the
ballot law commission which is H part of
the secretary's estate's office and they
they're pretty permissive and like who
can file what although they're set up to
make
decisions quickly and they're usually uh
they are usually uh they usually their
priority is usually to make the
decisions as non-disruptive as as
possible but that is another Avenue you
can file file uh if you have concerns
about how if an election was handled
improperly and also um what was it oh
also the one thing about the elections
is elections are very times sensitive
especially if you have an issue with a
uh the primary and I was just was
talking about a bot you know about an
hour ago I was here talking about a
ballot law commission proceeding which
is a related to the primary those they
have a very short turnaround time before
they have to get to the general election
and even in the general election um
there's not that much time between when
the winner of the general election takes
takes office so that's uh that's one
reason maybe not to have send things to
Superior Court and spend years you know
dealing with some dispute and possibly
leaving an office vacant also we have
frequent elections so even you know if
you think the wrong candidate loses the
election because of a violation of RSA
659 um there's there's another election
coming up shortly and also
elections just about all our elections
have federal Offices least the state
most of our elections have federal
office on them as well as State office
so you also have the option of of
seeking redress in the federal courts
although given what's happening the
federal government I hate to rely too
much on what the federal government will
or will not be doing in the future but
you do have the option of filing in in
federal court and um so I would just say
I just say this bill is unnecessary it
goes too far and um you know there may
be there may be some legitimate concerns
in there but you should probably itl it
and also if you're swayed by what uh
what rep what the representative from
Goffstown said and you're in kind of a
you're in although I will admit you're
in kind of a tricky position because
he's not just a member of the committee
but the chair but he alluded to
something that happened that involved
the election near ing um violation and
it might be useful if you think that's a
compelling reason to go forward with the
bill to maybe have some sort of work
session and try to get reach some sort
of consensus about exactly what it is
that happened to representative Barry
although and of course in all fairness
he might he probably would have wouldn't
have wanted to sue anyway even if this
law was passed because he actually won
his election so he wasn't really harmed
he may have been grieved by what
happened he may even have legitimate
reasons to seek R addess but he in fact
won so he wasn't actually technically
harmed by whatever it is that happened
but I will say if you're you might yes
once again you might want to nail down
exactly what that anecdote is and what
the established facts are and what
happened which is not really clear from
what he said so anyway that's uh gone
over my two minutes already so thank you
for your patience and uh so I you to itl
it and I suppose you enjoy your lunch
thanks okay thank you very much uh will
you take questions from sure yes other
questions from the
committee uh seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony thank you very
much make sure he gets his phone I'm
sure he'll notice it's missing
eventually but uh get it to him sooner
rather than later because I you bet I
know I hate misplacing my phone somebody
left there he is cool somebody left his
phone on the table there
representative all right well seeing no
further uh requests to testify
representative gzowski could you get me
the blue sheet please oh uh
okay are soon to be chairman
again yeah we
are and representative Nome if you could
do me the favor
again
okay um I see uh four people uh
testifying via the blue sheet against uh
adopting this bill as law and online is
in support 8 in opposition 259
thank you so much for reading that off
on me okay and with that I am closing
the public hearing
for hey we're still in a meeting here
I'm closing the public hearing for HP
514 we will meet again at 100 p.m. to
have several executive sessions you may
excuse
me
e
hello hello folks uh I'm going to our
chairman is uh unavoidably delayed due
to backlogs in the cafeteria says he'll
start back at 1:15 so I'm going to open
the first executive session and recess
it so I'm opening the executive session
on HB 365 FN we are going to recess it
until 1:15 if he's not back then we
we'll do the same thing again so we are
in recess till at least 1:15 thank you
and judging by the number of empty seats
well
e
okay we're going to open up the notice
executive session for the house election
law committee and I'm going to get my
notes out here I don't know why I Clos
them okay we'll just uh let's just start
with the top
I'm going to open the executive session
for House Bill 365 relative to proof of
United States citizenship for voters and
I will make the motion of ought to pass
is there a second I'll I'll second it
representative qua seconds is there
discussion on the motion of ought to
pass on House Bill
365 representative
Lane
um in the subcommittee we hadn't had a
chance to fully vet this um and uh we
were talking about requirements for
citizenship and what would work and um
our wonderful Legislative Assistant has
been helping us in getting uh
information so there is some question
about whether or not uh it's uh would
pass legal muster uh because it has been
challenged in other states and um has
been struck down and is there another
way to get uh proof of citizenship other
than um uh some having us have to
provide it to the government the
government in most part has proof they
either have our um birth certificates
they have records of our passports and
they have records of real uh ID so
instead of putting it on us our the
government already has a lot of this
information and why can't they provide
it either to the Secretary of State or
provide it to us directly to give so
that we don't have to because one of the
questions we came up with was
what is Indigent and we're going to take
an affidavit that you're poor but we
won't take an affid David that you are a
citizen it just didn't seem to make
sense logically so we were headed on
talking about it and so um we are going
to vote itl just because we think a lot
more work and I think there are other
ways to accomplish the goal that this
bill wants to do um and
uh we could do it in a different way um
that that does not put a burden on um
people because trying to prove
citizenship is expensive for people and
um and it takes months and months uh in
some cases so it just it doesn't seem
right uh to require it particularly for
those who can't afford an extra $500 to
get their citizenship papers thanks okay
further discussion on the bill um the
reason we're moving on this bill while
it's still in the subcommittee is it's
an early bill so we just we have to vote
on it today because tomorrow oh uh and
I'll make that announcement once we get
done with this vote but these first
three or three are early bills so I will
need those reports tonight um tonight no
exceptions because those have to be
reported out tomorrow so anyway we're on
the motion of a to a to pass um on House
Bill 365 does any other member wish to
speak hearing none are you ready for the
question the clerk will call the role on
65 representative qua yes representative
vernham yes representative warry yes
representative wood yes representative
Harvey volia yes representative C yes
representative gzowski yes
representative toner yes representative
Alexander yes representative Lane no
representative Ward no representative
Gilmore no representative Mirad no
representative Bay no representative
Grill no Representative willham no
representative Nome
no chairman Barry chair votes yes with
that the motion of out to pass carries
on a vote of 10 to eight I'll be
responsible for the majority report
representative Lane who will get the
minority minority report excuse me
um um representative would be
responsible for the majority report I
assume representative Mirad will be
responsible for the Minority Report
since he's flagging me okay with that we
will close the exec I session for house
uh for House Bill 714 reminder those
three bills are all early bills so I
need those reports tonight um because
they are due I have to have them in
tomorrow by noon so I need to have them
tonight because Lord knows what's going
to happen when we have a two-year-old at
home so
um next uh we'll open the executive
session for cacr 2 relating to the
drawing of District boundaries providing
that no District boundaries shall be
drawn in a way that favors or disfavors
any political party or candidate um I
will make the motion of inexpedient to
legislate is there a second second is
there any discussion on the motion of
inexp to legislate on cacr 2 represent
recognized I realized that there's some
issues with the way this was originally
drafted but I would like to have had the
chance to fix some of the issues that
were spotted but I also just want to
point out to everybody that this is one
of the most often cited reforms and
reasons for PE voters
um not liking our political system and
not participating because they do not
think that we should be redistricting
for ourselves that we should uh I mean
for our parties we should be
redistricting for our constituents
so the first discussion on the motion of
anyi to legislated on cacr
2 um the only comment that I will
add is it's an inherently political
process it's a messy process and
the more you try to divorce it from what
it actually is the more it just becomes
even worse in my opinion so I I
understand the points of it I understand
the argument for it um but when you look
at it at the end of the day somebody in
a political position somewhere is making
a decision about who's going to control
this so with that uh if you're ready for
the question the clerk will call the
role on the motion of inexpedient to
representative
qua yes representative Burnham yes
representative weary yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey bolia yes
representative C yes representative
gzowski yes representative toner yes
representative Alexander
yes representative Lane no
representative Ward no representative
Gilmore no representative Mirad no
representative Bay no representative
Grill no representative Willam
representative Nome nope chairman Barry
chair votes the yes with that the motion
of inexpedient to legislate on cacr 2
carries on a vote of 10 to8 I'll be
responsible for the majority report
representative Lane who will have the
minority I
think
representative okay we will close the
executive session on cacr 2 um and we
will open the executive session for for
House Bill 130 arrangement of candidates
on primary election ballots and I will
recognize representative wood for a
motion yes thank you Mr chair I'd like
to move a house bill 130 to it
representative wood mov inexpedient to
legislator on House Bill 130 is there a
second I'll second that representative
gasowski seconds is there discussion on
the motion of any speaked to legisl on
House Bill
130 yes representative just curious one
quick reason for
it be I'd be grateful if if there
someone offered a quick reason just C
out of curios someone someone is uh
someone can if they wish representative
wood the uh for for the elections they
were talking about the primary for the
uh state representative I was doubting
whether that first place position is as
valid as they this one person indicated
and also it seems like we will be adding
complication to the Ballance being
created so of the districts are a little
crazy with the full Tero so I just
didn't see the advantage for that
particular election and that was what
was spelled out in in
that yeah you're welcome further
discussion on the motion of inexperience
legislator on House Bill
130 he none you ready for the question F
rooll mistake okay here we go
representative quaale yes represent
resentative Burnham yes representative
warry yes representative wood yes
representative Harvey bolia yes
representative
C representative kovski yes
representative toner yes representative
Alexander yes representative Lane yes
representative Ward sorry
yes my glasses and I can't see um
representative Gilmore yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Bay yes representative Grill yes
representative wilham yes representative
Nome yes chairman Barry chair votes yes
without the motion of in expedent to
legislator on House Bill 1 130 carries
on a vote of 18 to Z is there any
objection to this bill being placed on
the consent calendar hearing none the
bill will be placed on consent calendar
representative wood you will be
responsible for the committee Report
with that we will close the executive
session on House Bill 130 we'll open up
the executive session for House Bill 154
enabling voters to request to have their
ballots handc counted and I will
recognize representative C for a motion
I move with u HB 154 be ought to pass is
there a second representative wey
seconds we're on discussion on the
motion of op to pass on House Bill 154
is there discussion on the
motion this is just a representative C
was recognized I'm sorry uh this is just
a straightforward uh thing to show that
voters do have the right to have their
ballots and counted further discussion
154 that doesn't worry um I'll I'll add
I hope that by I hope if this becomes
law that less people will do it does
that make sense like because they can
they won't um because right now we see a
lot of people doing like the ride in
bubble or intentionally over voting
basically forcing the issue and I'm
hoping that if voters see that they can
do this that they will just run their
ballot through the machine because they
have the option to um so that's my hope
um it's that I am not I do not have
enough roll call we you not have enough
roll call sheets okay I I'll I'll I'll
drag it out of course and we can we can
always stand in recess for a minute okay
yes representative Lane
um I I guess I just my concern is that
it's actually going to do the opposite
that more people are going to ask for it
and it's going to delay the counting of
votes and hand counting is show has been
shown to be less accurate than um
machine counting so I am hoping that I
am wrong in my concerns and um and we
shall
see further discussion I I would
actually echo part of that um obviously
we disagree on the effect but voters I
will issue a word of caution is when you
do this when you exercise this when you
do it either because you forced it or
we're potentially going to enable you to
do it you're say you're saying I want
somebody who's been up for 16 hours
straight
to pull out my ballot and read it
amongst other ballots that are either
put in that bin or had errors um and to
representative Lane's point my
experience in the recounts shows me that
the machines are far more accurate than
the people um and you do I you know I
think you have that right um but you
kind of take your ballot into you know
you you also have the right to suffer
the consequences of someone
unintentionally who's been up for 16
hours misinterpreting your intention on
the ballot should there be an issue um
I've never you know when we do these
recounts I always you know I always I
always help on my side with the recounts
and I always try to kind of council the
candidat that are going through this
it's like when you have a machine town
or machine lo location you'll see small
changes you'll always see small changes
because the people will fill out the
ballot wrong and something will be
something will be off and something will
change you'll see small changes and in
hand count towns you either see very
little change if any or you see a
massive move um because something went
horribly wrong so you kind of you kind
of take that anyways now that we've
delayed this long enough um oh yes
representative wood thank you Mr chair
uh you did bring something here's a
chance I for us to work as a bipartisan
on
this I was surpris how many people that
I know actually think they have the
right to do this and um that that whole
circumstance that happened really
affected some people because they
thought that something was taken away
from them I think what we can do as a
bipartisan is convince people that the
election uh the ballots or the the
machines work but I think they should
have the right to make that decision if
they see something that bothers them um
this this allows them to take it to the
moderator or to somebody else there and
have it done the oldfashioned way thank
you all right representative
Kilmore well and for the last I don't
know half dozen elections at least they
could just put it in the side machine
and it's never been an issue and there's
other ballots that are course are handc
counted yukaba and a couple others so I
don't really see what's a big deal here
but I thought I thought everybody had
that right right
already we all it makes you feel anybody
represent Gilmore I actually learned
something almost every day we have a
hearing or executive session I learn
something new about election laws and I
I consider myself in the ession lot of
people who are informed about it so um
all right with is there any other
discussion on the motion of ought to
pass on House Bill 154 hearing none are
you ready for the question the clerk
will call the role on the motion of
ought to pass on House Bill
154 representative qua yes
representative Burnham yes
representative weary yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey bolia yes
representative C yes representative
goovi yes representative toner yes
representative Alexander yes
representative Lane no representative
Ward no representative Gilmore yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Bay no representative Grill yes
Representative wilham no representative
Nome
no uh chairman Barry chair votes yes and
with that the motion of ought to pass on
house 154 carries on a vote of 12 to6
representative C you will be responsible
for the majority report representative
Lane who will have our Minority Report
representative Ward representative Ward
will have the Minority Report all right
with
that uh it was 12 do I thought it was 12
14 to
four yeah you're right I can't count um
let me just let me just well hold on
we're going to triple check here because
I thought I was counting along as I went
up I didn't I didn't hear represent hey
repres girl how did you vote I voted yes
okay I'm sorry that's where I messed up
um and representative Newsome he did
vote you voted no right oh you voted no
I'm sorry okay so we're it's all right
it's all right because we're we're both
wrong you had 14 I had 12 and then the
answer is 13 so so with that all right
so we'll try this again uh with the the
vot the motion on ought to pass carries
on a vote hand counting
people the motion the
motion the motion of ought to pass
carries on a vote of 13 to5 with a CAU
tale about hand counting um hand
counting ballots uh with that we will
close God works in mysterious ways we
will close the uh we will close the
executive session on House Bill
154 yeah that's right but I have a
question about turn on your
microphone oh yes I can interrupt for a
moment uh hb130 was that on the consent
calendar or not hb130 that's an NN so
yes it's no no it's a negative motion so
it go on the con it's it's a negative
motion it can go on the consent count
want to make sure I got that right thank
you is the oh okay
perfect
represent do you have who made those
motions kind of missed that when I was
that so4 the motion of a to pass was
made by representative C and it was
seconded by representative weie thank
you all right and next up is going to be
the
ever recessed House Bill 158 which I'm
recessing because I still have not
gotten my Amendment done but maybe once
we get through this it's not an early
158 it always as you know at this point
I just include it because it makes me
feel good um and now we will open up the
executive session for House Bill 363 and
I will recognize representative Lane for
a
motion I'd like to move to amend
representative well first we got make
open it I I would like u i I would like
to move to uh ought to pass all right
representative Lane moves ought to pass
on House Bill 363 is there a
second representative Ward seconds um
representative land do you have an
amendment uh yes I do thanks um I uh
handed out an amendment um the purpose
of this amendment was to address some of
the comments that were made at um the
public hearing so the the section that
was addressed uh compactness uh has been
taken out so that there are now uh six
requirements instead of five and then uh
on line 15 and 16 I've added in school
districts as a me a metric for um
communities of interests otherwise it's
the
same okay we're on discussion on
Amendment 20 25-
0682 on House Bill 363 I'm sorry did you
you move the amendment there was there
was a second by representative
correct we did that all right just
making sure because I can't count so
um trust but verify um so we're on
discussion of the amendment on with on
06682 move by representative Lane Is
there further discussion on the
amendment our rules our rules allow us
to take up amendments by a Voice vote
all those in favor of adopting the
amendment say I I all opposed say no the
eyes have it representative Lane would
you like to make a new
motion yes I would like to move a to
pass on uh HB
boy
225-0686
uh is there discussion on the motion of
amended hearing none the clerk will call
the role um you ready for the question
[Music]
go representative qua
no representative Burnham no
representative wey no representative
wood no representative Harvey bolia no
representative C no Representative
gzowski no representative toner no
representative Lane yes I'm sorry go
back to representative Alexander no
sorry about
that representative Ward
yes representative Gilmore yes
representative Mirad
yes representative Bay yes
representative Grill yes representative
wilham yes representative Nome yes
chairman Barry chair votes no with that
the motion of ought to pass as amended
on House Bill 363 fails on a vote of 8
to 10 I will make the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
363 is there a second representative
toner seconds is there a discussion on
the motion of inexpedient to legislate
hearing none are you ready for the
question can I ask who seconded that be
and the clerk will call hearing none the
clerk will call the role on the motion
of inexpedient to legislated on House
Bill
363 representative qua yes
representative Burnham yes
representative weary yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey Bia yes
representative C yes representative
gzowski yes representative toner yes
representative Alexander
yes representative
no no I'll you I'm not gonna trust
anything no I'm G to make sure I get the
right column
too representative Ward no
representative Gilmore no representative
Mirad no representative Bay no
representative Grill no Representative
willham no representative of Nome no
chairman Barry chair votes yes and with
that the motion of in expedient to
legislate on House Bill 363 Carona vote
of 10 to8 I'll be responsible for the
majority report representative Lane who
will be responsible for the Minority
Report um I am and everyone can now see
how poorly I multitask all right you
have a you have a chair with a bad ADHD
so you're I'm I'm like live in
multitasking land all day my brain so
it's not easy to keep up um but just
don't ask me to remember something um
with that we will close the executive
session on House Bill 363 um house bills
356 and 590 are going to be recessed um
to bring a package forward so we're
going to open up the executive session
on House Bill
367 uh changing the method of adopting
partisan Town elections to be the same
as as sending partisan Town elections um
and I recognize representative Wei for a
motion I'd like to make a motion ought
to pass representative William ought to
pass is there a second second
representative har buia seconds um I
know we don't normally talk much during
uh EXA um but there was a request to
actually explain what was going on here
because there was general interest so I
would highly recommend that the member
who made the motion of ought to pass
explain why because uh this will be one
of the times in election law where you
explanation thank you Mr chair uh so
this
is um really just uh leveling the
playing field you can resend partisan
Town elections so you you have the
option to of moving toward partisan Town
elections and um this just makes the
process for adopting them the same as
recent them so it's there's a currently
a method for resending partisan Town
elections this just makes uh adopting it
to be equivalent um and uh it levels the
playing field on in terms of how a town
approach uh yes representative Lane
recognized so how in the past have they
adopted it if they didn't have a way to
they they there hasn't been many towns
that have adopted this um but it's I I
believe that the purpose of the
legislation is to make the the the
method of adoption is the same as the
method of resending it so it's it comes
in one way and it comes out the same way
um to put it on the same playing to put
it on the I don't want to say the same
playing field but use the same mechanism
um but to your question was how have
they done in the past the answer is they
haven't much not right yeah unless that
was the the point you were trying to
evoke okay yes I figured I figured
that's where you were going with that
and I would I just thought I would
indulge you
so
um uh they used you know they used to do
partisan elections I was looking through
some old Manchester election history and
they used to have partisan elections um
uh and it just kind of wild looking
through local election results and
seeing partisan and at some point
somebody made the decision to move away
from it um you know generally speaking
and we have these bills on partisanship
and I I kind of just kind of more
globally speaking
i i i reject the notion that these are
nonpartisan elections I understand that
they're not listed on the ballot but if
you're if we're all going to sit here
and pretend like the parties aren't
engaging at this level at this point I
mean I live lived in Manchester for 12
years I will tell you right now the
Manchester Democrat committee and the
Manchester Republican committee were
both heavily involved in those quote
nonpartisan elections so I uh I
generally think more globally if you if
you at least
disclose what party someone is a part of
I I think you're going to see turnout in
the
horribly low turnout elections go up
because many voters are not engaged at
the minutia level um most people when
they move to town don't know who's
running and the only thing the only
piece of information that they might
have is partisanship and for some reason
we have decided to deny people that
indicator but a party you know a party
is not a brand loyalty for life it's
just more of a statement about who do
you more globally identify with I
certainly I'm a republican but I don't
identify with every
uh plank of the Republican platform I
co-sponsor the legalization of marijuana
I've been a longtime supporter of
marriage equality um but I'm very
conservative on government so I tend you
know there's other things I tend to
identify more with the Republicans than
not so somebody who who knows nothing
about me they're going to if they want
to vote for the candidate of limited
government that's the party you know
they're going to vote Republican if they
don't they're going to vote Democrat I
think when you deny them when you deny
the voter that piece of information I
think it actually decreases their
turnout I think it decreases their
knowledge when they're making a decision
um and the partisanship already exists
it's just we just pret we just choose to
pretend like it doesn't anyways that's
my that's my rant uh anyone else wants
to speak to uh House Bill
356 representative weary so just um it
um the RSA uh that addresses special
Provisions for partisan ballot systems
begins in 669
37 and uh carries on for
um several Pages after that so if people
are particularly interested in finding
out all the specific details of of that
area of the rsas that is the area to be
looking
at all right further discussion on the
motion of oop pass on House Bill
367 um representative
Gore thank you um the question I have is
this is for Town elections Do's a city
do I believe was the first city in the
state that went nonpartisan that was
well over 50 years ago um how's does
this affect cities could it C he go back
to no parison but you can't under
this that's my question that's a great
look I'm just reading it real fast
that's a great question though
procedure and outline is
6699 anybody beats me to it feel free to
Town line line two on page two any Town
may vote to
adopt the change referal into
towns yes but there is a method for
partisan
City chart I mean the cities operate
under a different system and I'm trying
is um I think it well I think to answer
representative Gilmore's question I
think it I think on face value it only
applies to towns um that's what the bill
says
[Music]
um but well I I do think that's more of
a I'm going to write that down because
that's actually I want to review that
statute for cities in general I the city
operates under the city char of course
and I think it's probably in there that
we'd have to do it but again I don't
know what the process is though it was a
city chart yeah and the name of chapter
districts yeah that's a great that's a
great
uh I'm have to do some research so thank
you I was GNA have to go go I said I
learn every time um all right further
discussion on the motion of ought to
pass on house 367 representative Newsome
you're recognized thank you um just a
quick question does this affect whether
it's on the business meeting or the
ballot uh so this is on the partisan
this is on the partisan official ballot
system so my guesses would it be it
wouldn't but I guess which way is it
before the legislation does that move it
from one to the other is the question I
don't believe it's it's not moving
anything it's adding um it's adding to
and taking away from
the it's it's editing 12 and 13 so it's
not really moving I guess I don't
understand the question I'm sorry well I
guess before the like today would it be
done during the business meeting or the
balloting oh you're asking how it would
be done today yes okay and does this
change that so whether from the business
meeting or the ballot system yep so
currently I I'll I'll read 1612 any Town
May adopt may vote to adopt the partisan
official ballot system for for election
of town officers under an article in the
warrant for any town meeting and may
resend such action in like manner the
partisan ballot system shall not be in
effect until Town election follow first
following the town meeting at which such
system is adopted a plurality shall
elect in towns using the partisan ballot
system did I did I sufficiently dodge
the question you dodged it very well but
then I guess it it begs a followup
question is that um the bill is says
that it is making the adoption and the
recision the same yet yeah what a messy
RSA they're taking resin such such
action in like manner yeah so we're
already there but why even have the and
that's that's I guess where my
additional confusion is coming from and
it's it's a fair point if I may Mr chair
go ahead yeah I think in 669 where it
talks about in any town in which so
three line three four lines down in
66913 talks about in any town in which
the partisan ballot system is in effect
and which has a population according to
most recent Federal right so it's line
20 it's struck yeah so can you just
strike that and then do you need this
because it's already in
here that was kind of where I was head
like yeah that's actually I think
representative Lane's making a good
point do you even need the rest of that
language because it already
says actually if it says oh I don't want
I don't want to still representative new
Thunder here no I tell you what let's uh
let's let's recess this bill okay I
think that there's there's
some I think I think it I told you
discussions was was needed I wasn't
wasn't holding the bag I was like you
don't want to talk about this one okay
why didn't people do does this mean
we're recessing with pending motion yeah
oh I should say yeah when we come back
we will be on the motion of ought to
pass so just like when we come back
we're just immediately back to that all
right
so now that we've burned up some brain
cells there okay um we'll uh move to oh
we'll open up to uh open up the
executive session for House Bill 481
relative to moving the state primary
date I will move that the bill be ought
to pass is there a second second
representative wood seconds um this is
the June bill for those trying to keep
track at home um this is the June bill
is there discussion on the motion of
ought to pass and no I don't feel the
need to make another speech
so tell me why I'm wrong all right I I
know you're I know you're devastated um
hearing none are you ready for the
question on the motion of a to pass on
House Bill 481 the clerk will call the
pass representative quaale yes
representative Burnham yes yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey volia yes
representative C yes representative
kovski yes representative toner yes
representative Alexander yes
representative Lane yes representative
Ward no representative Gilmore no
representative
Mirad
yes representative Bay no representative
Grill no Representative wilhem no
representative Nome
yes chairman Barry chair
enthusiastically votes yes um and now to
do math another hand
count
135 uh the motion of ought to pass on
House Bill 41 will carry out on a passes
on a vote of 13 to five and um I will
take care of the majority report and I
appreciate the bipartisan camarad on
that one um I really do we close the 13
to5 Minority Report oh I'm sorry yeah is
there a Minority Report I apologize
representative Grill Min report my
apologies my
apologies um all right with that we will
close the executive session on House
Bill 481 I got so excited
just yes I understand uh we have a long
waiting a long oh and there's the
warning and there's the
warning and there's the warning uh
going to open up the executive session
for House Bill 481 relative to moving
the state primary date sorry we just did
481 sorry excited House Bill 408 moving
the state primary date to the fourth
Tuesday in August and I will make the
motion of inexpedient to legislate on
that one is there a second second is
there a discussion on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on uh House
Bill 408 the August
Bill the August like how I use the
negative the negative kind of pres in
August all right uh hearing none the
will call the role on the motion of
408 representative qua yes
representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey Balia
representative C yes representative
kovski yes representative toner yes
representative Alexander yes
representative Lane no representative
Ward no representative Gilmore no
representative
Mirad no representative Bay no
representative Grill no representative
Wilhelm no represent representative Nome
no chairman Barry chair votes yes
without the motion of inexpedient to
legislator on house B 48 passes on
carries on a vote of 10 to8 I'll be
responsible for the majority report who
is responsible for the Minority Report
representative Oh I thought I thought
repres girl she going to do both of them
it's just kind ST stand up for we're not
not September
forever theity no it's representative
Wilhelm for The Minority Report after I
will eagerly await uh that we will close
the the executive session on House Bill
408 and representative C is your
Amendment ready for
151 I I just need to know if I need to
ready we had already oh that's right
okay so we already have it all right so
we'll open up the uh executive session
for House Bill 151 relative to the term
of Supervisors of the checklist I'll
recognize representative C for a motion
move ought to pass representative C
moves ought to pass on house 151 is
there a second representative weary
seconds
um is there um is there an amendment to
present uh yes Amendment
058 Z do we have copies of that
Amendment uh we were given that on uh
during the public hearing okay um I
don't want to vote on the amendment if
it's not directly in front of the
members I don't think that's fair um
also I don't want to vote on without
being in front of me can we can let's
put in a re Mr Mr Alan can you can you
find that Amendment get us copy so I'm
sorry you're just here I apologize I
know it's not your job but thank you so
much so we'll we will we will try to
come back to this today but I think I
don't think it's fair to vote on
amendment when it's not in front of
you oh that
he P all right so we'll we'll recess it
we'll come back um today
and then we will open up the executive
session for House Bill 600 enabling rank
Choice voting I'll recognize
representative Harvey bullia for the
purpose of a motion I make a motion of
itl Mr chair on House Bill 600
representative buum is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 600 is there a
second I second it representative qua
seconds it we're now on discussion on
the motion of inexpedient to legislate
on House Bill 600 representative Wilhelm
is recognized thank you chair
uh I am going to vote against the itl
motion uh rank Choice voting it's a
widely accepted tested improved method
of voting um this is an enabling bill it
allows municipalities uh to make the
decision that's right for their
communities uh won't cost taxpayers
anything uh in fact it may save some
municipalities uh you know I think we've
seen across the country that it's uh you
know easy to understand easy to
administer um you know and it really
offers an opportunity to
provide uh really a a chance
to give voters uh more choices uh would
improve uh the quality of campaigning
would improve the uh the tenor of
campaigns uh which I think uh Granite
Staters deserve you know if their
municipality decides to go with it so
it's a local control issue and um I
think we should Empower our
municipalities to make the best
decisions uh for them thanks
representative hary buly is recognized
thank you Mr chair real quick um I know
rank choice this bill uh promised a lot
of things but there are three main
things uh that are going against it and
one it threatens fast and accurate
ballot counting uh it produces slow
results and more regularity it has
technical problems which I'm aware of uh
working in in the industry um there's at
least three states that I saw that had
technical software issues or hardware
issues uh regarding these uh the system
number two it diminishes voter
confidence it's overly complicated it is
confusing it requires voters to make
decisions on all the candidates which a
lot of Voters don't and three the worst
thing about this is it uh leads to to
gamesmanship in voting thank
you further discussion representative
Gilmore shiz well for all that you just
said it seems to be very popular in the
states in which it exists seems to be
very popular in the countries in which
it exists and the person with the
highest votes actually gets a plurality
is the winner so I'm I'm all in favor of
it further discussion on the motion of
600 hearing none you ready for the
question Mar call the RO and the motion
of in speed to
legislate representative qua yes
representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey Bia yes
representative C yes representative
kovski yes representative toner yes
representative Alexander representative
Lane no representative Ward no
representative Gilmore no representative
Mirad no representative Bay no
representative Grill no Representative
willhelm no representative Nome nope
chairman Barry chair votes yes without
the motion of any speed to legislate
cares on a vote of 10 to8 uh
representative hary bolia will be
responsible for the majority report
representative Lane who will have our
Minority Report uh representative
Wilhelm representative Wilhelm will have
our Minority Report with that we will
close the executive session on House
Bill 600 we now have the amendment for
uh House Bill 151 I'd like to thank our
wonderful legislative staff for moving
so quickly on that thank you um it's
coming around so we are going to reopen
the executive session I recognize
representative C for a motion to move an
amendment
okay I'll wait for it to get
0580 representative C moves Amendment
2025-the
the
amendment representative C is recognized
the uh Amendment just simply uh takes
care of either an oversight or a typo uh
because it was going to threeyear terms
instead of six-year terms that meant
that uh elections had to occur in every
years is there further discussion on the
amendment
all right uh our rules allow us to adopt
amendments by Voice vote all in favors
of adopting Amendment 2025 j05 80h to
house po 151 say I I all opposed say nay
the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted representative C is recognized
for a
motion I move ought to pass with
Amendment representative C moves ought
to pass as amended on house B 151 with
Amendment 2025
0588 is there a second representative
seconds we're now in discussion on the
motion of ought to pass as amended is
there discussion on the motion of ought
to pass as
amended hearing none are you ready for
the question the clerk call the role on
a on the motion of ought to pass as
Amendment on House Bill
0580 representative qua yes
representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey Balia yes
representative C yes representative
gzowski yes representative toner yes
representative Alexander yes
representative Lane yes representative
Ward yes representative Gilmore
yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Grill yes representative Wilhelm yes
representative Nome yes chairman Barry
chair votes yes with that the motion of
ought to pass as amended carries on a
vote of 18 to zero um representative C
you'll be responsible for the committee
report is there any objection to this
bill being placed on the consent
calendar hearing none the bill will be
placed on the consent calendar um with
that we will close the executive session
on House Bill 151 and we will open up
the executive session on uh House Bill
412 is going to be accessed as part of
those partisan um School bills uh we're
going to open up the executive session
for House Bill
429 relative to amending the term of the
length of County Commissioners
representative wood is recognized for a
motion yeah I'm I'm moveing HB
429 for itl please representative wood
moves inexpedient to legislate on House
Bill 429 is there a second second
representative toner seconds more
discussion on the motion of any speeding
to legislator House Bill 429 is there
any discussion
hearing none are you ready for the
question the clerk will call the rooll
on the motion of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
ready thank you for your patience
representative qua yes representative
Burnham yes representative warry yes
representative wood yes representative
Harvey bolia yes representative C yes
representative gzowski yes
representative toner yes representative
Alexander yes representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes representative
Gilmore yes representative
Mirad yes representative Bay yes
representative Grill yes representative
Willl Hound yes representative Nome
yes and chairman Barry chair votes yes
without the motion of any expedient to
legislator and House Bill 429 carries on
a vote of 18 to Z is there any is there
any objection this bill being placed on
consent calendar hearing none the bill
will be placed on consent calendar um
representative wood you'll be
responsible for the major for the
committee
Report with that we will close the
executive session on House Bill
429 and we will open the executive
session for House Bill 333 requiring
moderators to designate a space for
election yearing in at polling places
and provide a schematic thereof and I
recognize representative Harvey bullia
for a motion thank you Mr chair I uh
make a motion of itl on House Bill 333
representative Harley bullly mes
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
333 is there a second second
representative wood seconds is there
discussion on the motion of any speeding
333 hearing none of you ready for the
question the clerk will call the role on
the motion of inexpedient to legislate
on House Bill 333 when she is ready
representative qua yes representative
Burnham yes representative warry yes
representative wood yes representative
Harvey Balia yes representative C yes
representative kovi yes representative
toner yes representative
Alexander representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes representative
Gilmore yes representative Mirad
representative Bay yes representative
Grill yes representative Wilhelm yes
representative Nome yes chairman Barry
chair votes yes and with that the motion
of inexpedient to legislate on House
Bill 333 carries on a vote of 18 to zero
is there any objection to this bill
being placed on the consent calendar
hearing none the bill will be placed on
consent calendar representative Harley
bullia you will be responsible for the
committee report we Cur close the
executive session on House Bill 333
recessed House Bill 409 was withdrawn I
apologize for noticing it um so we're
not going to take it up it's on the
calendar for Thursday on the withdrawn
calendar so we're not taking it up um
House Bill I'm going I will open the
executive session for House Bill 220
closing the presidential or state
primaries of political parties I will
make the motion of inexpedient to
legislate is there a second
we'll take the second from
representative Ward we'll go
bipartisan
um word I said word sorry just behind oh
it's okay no
worries did the motion I
did uh I don't need to give my speech
again I gave it last time it's the same
bill um is there any is there any
discussion on the motion of any speeding
to legisl on House Bill 220 hearing none
the clerk will call the role and the
motion of inexpedient to legislate when
representative qua yes representative
Burnham yes representative warry yes
representative wood yes representative
Harvey bolia yes representative C yes
representative gzowski yes
representative toner yes representative
Alexander representative Lane yes
represent representative Ward yes
representative Gilmore yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Bay yes representative Grill yes
representative wihelm yes representative
Nome yes chairman Barry chair votes yes
with that the motion of any being to
legislate carries on a vote of 18 to
zero is there any objection to this bill
being placed on the consent calendar
heing none the bill will be placed on
the consent calendar I will be
responsible for the committee report we
have no other bills today uh we're going
to close executive session for 220 we
have no other bills today today a
reminder 365 521 and 714 I need those
reports tonight tonight tonight tonight
um everything else it's we're not going
to see these bills for a couple so it'
be nice to get them in we can get them
up but with that uh I'll see you guys on
Thursday we will have executive session
next week it will only be executive
session we have no more hearings we
actually did our last hearing today so
yay us 7 we have I don't think yay for
us 75 bills we got through all of them
thank you um I felt like it was a
Monumental task but I guess not um um so
we will have it um I haven't quite
decided on the time yet so before
everybody goes is there I is it is town
meeting day we're only doing executive
session is there a preferred time we
don't have to meet at 10: a.m. um but is
there a preferred time do we just want
to meet at 10: a.m. anyways and get it
done and be done with or do you want to
go later in the day I just so anybody
have a strong opinion be done with
meeting be done with all right 10 a.m.
next Tuesday for executive session
that'll be similar to this there'll be
like 30 some OD bills on it all right I
will see you guys next I'll see you on